well hello there you're watching the
press preview first look of course at
what's on the front pages as they arrive
it's time to see what's making the
headlines with the daily mails
consultant editor andrew pearce and the
daily mirrors associate editor kevin
mcguire very good evening to you well
let's see what's on some of those front
pages and of course we know what it will
be but different treatments in all the
papers the long goodbye reads the front
of the eye as the queen is pictured
lying in state in westminster
the metro also shows a poignant picture
of the queen's coffin with the headline
our jewel her crown
the prince and princess of wales and the
duke and duchess of sussex are pictured
on the front of the mirror alongside the
headline pride and the pain as the
queen's family mourns
we share your pain reads the front of
the sun alongside this similar picture
of the couples
shoulder to shoulder reads the front of
the daily star
on the front of the guardian shows the
king following the coffin of the queen
as it is carried into westminster
the front of the times pictures other
members of the queen's family with the
headline a nation pays its respects
and the daily express shows cues of
people waiting to pay their respects to
her majesty with their headline your
nation stands with you ma'am
nation's turn to say farewell reads the
front of the daily telegraph
she lies at peace as her people bid
solemn farewells reach the front of the
daily mail
and the financial times also pictures
the queen's final resting place in
westminster but its headline looks at
the chancellor's plans to scrap
britain's cap on bankers bonuses and
just to remind you by scanning the qr
code you'll see on the screen join the
program you can check out those front
pages of the papers while you watch us
discussing them well as i say we're
joined tonight by the daily mirrors
associate editor kevin mcguire and the
daily mails consultant editor andrew
pearce and we are going to dive straight
in remarkable pictures are on all of
them aren't they let's say look first of
all gentlemen at the express your nation
stands with you ma'am and that just
lovely picture inside it's fabulous it's
historic westminster hall the oldest
part of the palace of westminster the
ceremony the procession today powerful
and moving i was in hyde park and i was
watching it with hundreds of people on a
giant screen it was incredibly moving
impossible for me as a devout monarch
not to find it so moving i was crying
and um i was with a member of the house
of lords he was crying too it and and
this headline i think sums it up because
the royal family have now given her back
the queen to the country to the people
and the people can now pay their
respects and tribute to the queen by
filing into uh the palace of westminster
i'd love to be able to say i could do it
but the queue is already two and a half
miles long uh and it's gonna be and
getting longer and getting longer it's a
fantastic use of the picture by the
daily express it's a very very good
front page
it's in the same group as the daily
mirror same owners but i don't normally
like the daily express from pages but i
think that's done really really
well because of course it has the queen
there and a coffin it has the guard and
then it has the public the people filing
down
either side and that's the oldest part
of parliament 900 years old and she
addressed both houses of parliament in
there five times and there are little
plaques not far from where she now lies
commemorating those addresses and it is
that point kevin that andrew's making
isn't it that um there's been a kind of
junction today in the process last night
when the queen was brought home to
buckingham palace and then we we weren't
seeing inside the coffin rested in the
bow room that was for the family and
then this transition today at 2 22
precisely when the procession started
that's when the state took over
yeah and they left and they fouled away
they left her they left her in the in in
the han in the hands of the people in
and there she's going to be till what is
it 6 20 or something on monday morning
until the day they've had a long time to
plan this of course but it's absolutely
meticulous
no expense spared in the in the in the
production and if you're a news editor
tv radio newspaper
you would think there's almost a a big
development a picture a moment each day
it's incredible how how they've uh but
this followed followed this through this
is international this is dominating from
pages all around the world there's talk
that the tv audience for the funeral
will be the biggest in history
there's no doubt
i'm not a monarchist but the world will
effectively come to london on
monday to be at westminster abbey from
joe biden down it's kind of
jostling for invitations it's stopping
people coming well a lot of them are
here now in those queues as well let's
let's have a look at another of these
pictures uh a different angle on
westminster all in the eye the long
goodbye and uh as you're saying it's
four days 24 hours a day of lying in
state
yeah which is a long period but i don't
think there's going to be any gaps in
that queue i was wandering along near
southern bridge earlier on and there's a
kind of community
spirit there almost carnival at times
and that's no disrespect meant by the
people in it uh so there will be arch
monikers some will be going along just
because it's become um an event not
curious there were some tourists too
but it's there it's not going to shorten
it's also how people are reacting
sometimes they're clapping yeah and
other times they're not it's silent it's
respectful and they're clapping and the
clapping is very
it's very nicely done and it's almost as
if they know when to clap and when not
to and i find that makes it even more
moving and powerful and what do you make
um of the motivation of people going
andrew i mean we saw we reporting on
there and some people in the crowd
there's a woman taking a tiny baby along
and that is for posterity isn't it so as
you can get that photograph of the child
that in 20 30 40 years time you can say
look at you then yeah you were at the
the most historic uh significant funeral
probably since winston churchill more
significant than winston churches i
would argue it's the first state funeral
since churchill in 1965 the most famous
woman in the world the most enduring
monarch in the world there's never going
to be a british monarch who will get to
a platinum jubilee and you were there as
a
as a child my mum and dad you know were
outside buckingham palace they slept
outside buckingham palace for the
coronation my mum was already pregnant
with her first child my sister they
because they wanted to be part of this
and you grew up in the family with those
pictures then absolutely and um
they saw a flash of the of the
coronation carriage they still remember
the queen of tonga who had the uh
carriage open and it was pouring with
rain and there was a little man
in the carriage in front of her and and
somebody said who's the man in the um
in the carriage with her and um what's
his name that the great playwright said
it's her lunch i mean it was just an
extraordinary day a mum and dad said
they would never have missed it for
anything even though they hardly saw
anything of the queen i grew up in a
household with a different tradition to
that on royal issues
look diana was a huge event at the time
it was it was a shock i mean that was
the difference isn't it
but if you see if you but if you gauge
it on newspaper sales after after a big
event the rise in newspaper sales have
been bigger the queen than they were
with diana and you're right it was a
shock in one way 96 year old
woman who we know is being in poor
health dies is is not a shock in itself
although the timing it just feels like a
shell coming from yeah well well it is i
mean the reality is
we thought she'd go on forever it was
wasn't it um charles said or was it was
it boris said in his speech we thought
she'd go on fraternity we thought she'd
go on and on we do not know any
difference it's emotional isn't it yeah
because there are other events in
people's lives that have much bigger
impact like a general election the
brexit vote joining the european union
there are a lot of events that will have
far more impact on how we live our lives
but she was she was there
and people were very fond of her and
respected her and if you're all around
the world and yeah but if you're if
you're
king charles iii as he is now and
queen is dead long live the king you
will be concerned that some of the
hereditary monarchy has died with her
and we are seeing a moment
that will not be repeated in 20 25 years
whenever
there's a there's a change again they
won't i just i will predict and hope to
be alive that they will not be
a response like this and to that end to
your point kevin i suspect a lot of
these front pages a lot of these papers
with these remarkable pictures and of
course plenty more to come most notably
on monday for the state funeral these
are being squirreled away by people
souvenir collectors
so many kevin and i were speaking event
this morning and um
the woman on the stage said i bought
every single newspaper the day after the
queen died and i'm keeping them forever
and i've got
we've got lots at home the times the
telegraph the tip and the mail because i
want to keep them wrap them in plastic
let's have a look there now another
another of these this is a close-up in
the metro a close-up of that procession
from buckingham palace long slow down
the mouth through horse guards along
white hall
through into the houses of parliament
and then ultimately to westminster
i mean what did you make of that with
with echoes again of diana's funeral
with the royals walking slowly behind
and william and william and harry we
know there's the problems in that
relationship which i don't sense i've
been fixed this week but they are
recreating that walkthrough which they
did with their mother what was william
11 harry was 11. william was 14.
it was very very different it felt cruel
back in 97 that you had two young boys
being required to walk behind the
funeral cortege of their mother now
they're they're older yeah
and it's their grandmother and the
grandmother's children charles edward
andrew anne they're all adults so we
feel it feels
very different yeah and very very
different and it's a clever headline
isn't it our jewel her crown yeah very
clever very clever again the metro do so
many clever front pages
but on the royals behind i mean it was
noted wasn't it that um andrew and harry
having both served in war zones were not
in military uniform and there's going to
be an exception made for prince andrew
on sunday night when they do the the
prince's
the vigil the vigil uh so he's going to
be able to wear a uniform but harry
won't harry of course was in
did two act up the tours of active
service in afghanistan andrew was in the
falklands and he could have died but um
they are not working royals so that's
the that's the that's the rules bends
the rules and then they're making an
exception for andrew because his mother
you know why don't they wear the the
uniforms or the ranks they had rather
yeah then you look like blood yeah
charles is a field martial he's never
been a field martial it's kind of a not
a retired auras but now he's commander
in chief yeah uh princeton was in the
royal marines for 12 weeks until he led
it because he didn't didn't like it but
he's wearing regalia but harry
did two tours in afghanistan uh but this
was his andrew
whatever else i think about him he was
in combat
this was his decision to walk away from
his duties and he knew when he walked
away from his duties he lost all his um
honorary roles
they don't wear the
the uniforms of the ranks they held when
they actually serve because they'd be so
junior to the others who have a lot of
braids and swords he'd have been
prepared to be colonel in chief of this
and the other regiments that he's
princess sam let's have a another look
at one of these uh the headlines and
it's the pictures though that do jump
out the daily telegraph
nation's turn to say farewell that point
that we've been making this evening i
want to focus though on the photograph
and you know your thoughts about those
young men the bear the bearer party the
precision with which they carried the
coffin in westminster you can see you
can see not only they you can see how
young they are because of
their faces none of them are wearing
metals which means they've not got any
long service medals and that was the
same uh when they were kept
in um uh the last time we saw them with
the queen
and they did it brilliantly i mean one
of them was sweating profusely wouldn't
you be sweating graffiti it's a very
heavy 30. well i mean that was that was
from wearing the hat yeah
but that coffee was taken from the queen
the queen was tiny but that coffin is
oak
and heavy because they they rehearse
with the
correct weight uh yeah i don't know what
they put in for the rehearsals uh big
grim think of it uh but they are so well
drilled yeah and they're just brilliant
on what they do because you know you're
you know you are worried that there's
going to be a slip and there's going to
be a catastrophe and they'd never live
it down but they don't time after time
after time we were saying they just
performed brilliantly it's not just
their mum and dads are watching their
grandparents are watching the whole
world is watching them and marveling and
they're a magnificent advertisement for
the british absolutely yeah they really
are and just continuing i mean it's just
so interesting looking at the pictures
then behind that we you know we wondered
where
the women were apart from the princess
royal who was walking of course behind
the coffin and we can see her there just
behind the king but then
lined up there there there they all were
the the queen consort and all the other
wines
it's interesting because prince william
is now uh he's now the prince of wales
and he's heir to the throne but he's not
behind his father he's behind the older
royals so he's behind the queen's
children quite interesting in the lineup
because they're they're taking center
stage which i thought was quite
interesting um yeah
princess anne's husband who is a a rear
admiral who's been everywhere in this
view he's been with the princess royal
all the way with the whole way through
because he's clearly very close to the
queen and they they're just about to
celebrate the 30 20 but it is one of
those photographs you look and you you
see something else something new every
time if you if you study it there's i
don't know who the guy is on the stairs
they're saluting yeah who he is i'm sure
he's very important in protocol paging
aleister
brilliant some of the women in black
side are the queen's ladies in waiting
so people like lady susan huss who'd
been with the queen for
decades
real blow for her because she's been
almost like a sister to the queen and i
imagine angela angela kelly i would
imagine who um is the queen's dresser
i'm sure she's in that the way the
children line up first and then you get
the grandchildren after it yeah there is
protocol it's a state occasion it's very
public but it's also very personal and
it's a family
there wasn't a step out of place was
that by anyone everyone knew their place
everyone
glided into position and they left at
222 from the palace and they got exactly
the time they were you could set your
clock to the second extraordinary the
music was haunting
big ben type
chiming oh my god so powerful got
another uh photograph
in the mirror front of the mirror it's a
pretty similar one on the front of the
sun as well and uh there's a lot to read
into this picture and i think the mirror
have got the headline just right the
pride
and the pain well let's look through
them i mean there's an inset there of
the king but um the prince and princess
of wales first yeah i mean look at the
biting of lips you can see the distress
on both of them
prince charles has looked to stress the
whole time we've seen him i mean
not least when he made that remarkably
powerful emotional address to the nation
and you can see it again he's struggling
to hold his emotions harry and megan at
the back pride in the pain so you could
read this headline a couple of ways the
pride the pride proud of the queen and
we're proud of the prince of wales and
princess of wales and the pain of prince
charles or is the pain referring to
harry and megan because they have been a
pain well it would have been a big pain
you may say
but there's the rift between the yeah
yeah and that's cause the brothers then
there's the rift between the wise and
there's a rift with harry and meghan who
are accusing the royal family of at
least one of them being racist we never
quite discovered one and then denying
their
son a
a title of a prince because somehow
because of his color i mean there's
there's a book coming out by
harry soon we know not when but i mean
but quite clearly that is all put aside
yeah
well they they'll have a they'll be
united in the grief over the last year
that is a deliberately ambiguous
headline in the mirror and i think it's
clever in itself and don't just look at
uh and the sons is similar just look at
the group of four um
well we we don't get this in the sun but
uh the duke and duchess of sussex some
gripping each other holding
hands tightly yeah she's probably very
nervous
because she's not used to it in this at
all i mean kate's been a part of the
royal family now for a very long time i
can't remember how long they've been
married it's 10 or 11 years so this is
all still
still new to her and harry is supporting
her you look at harry's face there i'd
love to know what he's thinking i mean
that is a man lost in boston thought
well he's been well that's i mean you
know that is the look of someone holding
it together
yeah and he was incredibly close to the
queen but he spent in the last two or
three years living in america he's
hardly seen her lily bet got to see the
queen just once uh
so um
he he's he's he'll he'll be going
through all sorts of emotions well
you'll have some regrets
i mean you just just apply what you
would do in your family to their family
i mean
they kind of put on a pedestal but
nevertheless at the end of the day they
are they are a family and it's just and
just one one last point on this picture
it is the prince of wales then looking
away not quite at the camera just to the
the left of the camera but but just
looking this way
that's the pain as well yeah you know in
the you know the past
his dad his father has been a bit miffed
everybody's sons have stolen the
limelight on the front the front of
newspapers and the pictures but that is
the picture yeah i think that and he and
he is the next generation
he'll be king himself one day and uh
ex and
again him and catherine haven't put foot
wrong have they i mean she is the great
star i think the royal family catherine
middleton uh what well the princess are
welcome
wales yeah
last last quick one on the financial
times well really twin headlines i
suppose you'd expect it's quite an
explosive story they've got the
chancellor to end cap on bankers bonuses
maybe we'll get to discuss that more in
the next hour but uh top of the paper
royal family escorts queen in procession
to westminster i think the ft's had a
picture of the of the funeral i think it
happens every single day on the front
page and a story on the front page
because their readers are interested too
most of the royal stories the ft have
been a single paragraph on the front and
no more yeah but that's a very powerful
picture again and again you see that you
see the king you see the four key
members of the royal family but just a
just a quick thought then kevin on quasi
quartering the chancellor set to end the
cap
on bankers bonuses well i'll be very
unpopular but it's gonna be it's going
to be a government a small state uh cut
taxes as it says and deregulation but
i think people at the moment want a big
state that will protect them and serve
them and you do bankers really deserve
more bonuses well you know i'll make a
controversial point of that if you give
them bigger bonuses it's uh 47 tax rate
which presumably they're on well we get
nearly half of it
yeah i think i think you'll find you'll
get more money by just taking the
bonuses i'm not i'm not into the
laughing i'm not into the lafayette the
listen he wants he wants to he wants to
make the city a key place
he wants to keep keep its place as one
of the main city uh economies in the
world and bankers bonuses are a key part
of that uh if they earn it they know
what he wants says he wants to give a
bong to the uh people who fired the tour
that's what he did yeah
the tory party is the political wing of
fight
he's a big touring donor tell me which
one
political hostilities as we've seen have
ceased in parliament for this period of
mourning they'll cease here in the sky
news studio as well